تبادلت روسيا واوكرانيا الاتهامات
بالمسؤوليه عن تفجير سد مدينه نوفاكاخوفكا
الواقعه بخيرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا وفيما
اكدت موسكو ان الجيش الاوكراني قصف السد
متسببا كذلك في تدمير محطه مجاوره لتوليد
الطاقه الكهرومائيه بهدف حرمان شبه جزيره
القرم من المياه ردت كييف بان الروس فجروا
السد لتعطيل هجومهم المضاد المخطط له
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات باحثيات تفجير
وما مقاصد المسؤول عن تفجيره في هذا
التوقيت وما حجم الكارثه بالنظر الى
الاثار الناجمه عن انهيار اجزاء من السد
وارتفاع منسوب المياه المتدفقه منه والى
اي حد يمكن احتواء تداعياتها الانسانيه
والبيئيه والغذائيه والى ماذا يؤشر هذا
المستوى من التصعيد بين الجانبين وهل ينذر
بدخول المواجهات مرحله جديده من الصراع
وما هي فرص خفض التصعيد في ظل الحراك
الدولي ودعوه مجلس الامن للانعقاد
[موسيقى]
لم يرفع تفجيره سد مدينه نوفاكا خوفكا فقط
مستوى المياه المتدفقه من جداره الذي افسح
المجال لسيول باتت تهدد حياه الاف الناس
وانما رفع كذلك مستوى المخاوف من دخول
الحرب في اوكرانيا مستوى جديدا غير مسبوق
على وقع تلويح متصاعد من قبل كييف بهجوم
مضاد واسع ووشيك الكريملين النفا بشده ان
تكون موسكو ضالعه في تفجير السد مؤكدا ان
الجيش الاوكراني هو من يقف وراء قصف السد
في عمل وصفه بالتخريب المتعمد في المقابل
اكدت اوكرانيا ان قصف السد عمل روسي شنيع
الغايه منه تعطيل الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
المرتقب هجوم باتا سؤال عن توقيت انطلاقه
اكثر الحاحا في ضوء تصاعد العمليات
القتاليه وبث السلطات الاوكرانيه دعايه
عسكريه تشير الى الصمت كحاجه لانجاح خطوط
عسكريه الكبيره ضد الروس
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو الكسندر
ارتمانوف الخبير وفي الشؤون العسكريه
والدوليه
ومنك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق
ومن عمان اللواء فايزه الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكم جميعا
ابدا معكم
في سرديه روسيا موسكو تقول بان كييف هي من
قامت بهذا العمل ما مصلحتكيف في الاساس
بان تقوم بتفجير سيفيض باتجاه الضفه
اليمنى التي تسيطر عليها وفي ظل تحضيراتها
لما تسميه هجوما مضادا وشيكا باتجاه
الاماكن التي هي بحوزه القوات الروسيه
تعلمون ان اوكرانيا اولا لم تبدا قصف السد
اليوم فقط السد كان في حالات حرجه واذكر
ان قبل نصف سنه عندما كانت خرسون تحت
السيطره الروسيه
اذ كان هناك صواريخ هايمه ضربت مدخل السد
وهذه صواريخ لا يمكن ان يخلط بينها وبين
الصواريخ الروسيه هناك ضربات عديده كانت
ضد هذا المنشا واما المياه التي
تقوم
بالسيل التي تسيل من السد ممكن ان تغرق اي
من الجانبين حيث القوات الروسيه ايضا لذلك
بالنسبه لما افهمه انا
القوات الاوكرانيه في هذا الجانب ما
تستطيع ان تقوم بهجمات على الجانب الروسي
لذلك عندما تسالين لماذا تقوم بهذا اريد
ان اقول لك ان الهجمات العكسيه قد بدات
فعلا ولكنها دون اي نجاح وهم يقوموا
بمحاولات قطع النهر
ولكن القوات
الاوكرانيه ليست حمقاء ولكنهم لن يستطيعوا
بهجمات من هذا الجانب لذلك ليس لروسيا اي
مصلحه من قصف السد الذي يقع تحت سيطره
القوات الروسيه والمدينه هذه تحت السيطره
الروسيه لم نفجرها ولا من اجانب من
الجوانب عدا عن ما حدث اليوم
اذا كما يتحدث السيد ارطمانوف هو يعني
يتصق مع ما تقوله
موسكو يعني عكس تماما ما تتحدث عنه كيف ما
مصلحه السؤال ذاته يطرح ما مصلحه
موسكو في ان تقوم بمثل هذا العمل
يعني في الوقت الذي يعني هي تتحدث فيه بان
الضرر سيطول ايضا الاماكن التي تسيطر
عليها بطبيعه الحال وايضا سيطول ايضا
امدادات المياه لشبه جزيره القرمه التي
تعتمد بشكل خاص على
الري من قبل مياه هذا اسد
سمعنا
وجهه النظر الروسيه لما حدث من جديد اعتقد
ان روسيا تحاول ان تكذب للعالم كله اليوم
من المستحيل ان نخفي الحقيقه وفي الايام
القريبه سوف يكون هناك الكثير من الحقائق
والدلائل على ان روسيا هي من قامت بهذا
وان اوكرانيا ما كانت لتملك الوسائل
التكنولوجيه لتدمر هذه المنشاه اما سؤالك
عن مصلحه روسيا ليس لدي اي رد لانه فعلا
ليس هناك اي مصلحه لروسيا من هذا لذلك
الرد الوحيد الذي يبقى عندي هو ان المصلحه
هي محاوله الضرر بالنظام الاوكراني فقط
الضرر بالنظام الاوكراني من خلال ايضا
اذيه نفسها هل هذا ما قلت
[موسيقى]
ان هذا شيء معتاد للجانب الروسي لان هذا
ما يسمى في المثل الروسي اطلق النار على
ركبتك لانها بهذه الطريقه
قامت بمنع الماء العذب عن القرم وهذه احد
العوامل اما الشيء الثاني قامت روسيا
بالتشكيل وربما هذه هي النيه الحقيقيه
شكلت مشكله كبيره لاوكرانيا لان هذه
الكارثه التي تعتبر غير مسبوقه في التاريخ
المعاصر لذلك اوكرانيا الان مضطره لتحويل
مصادرها الى انقاذ المواطنين وسوف يكون
هناك مشكله في تامين المياه العذبه للمدن
الساقطه على اضفه نهر النمر المشاكل
البيئيه اكثر عن ربما الكيفيه التي قصف
بها اسدنا اللواء فايز الدويري يعني في
عجاله نريد ان نعرج على هذه الجزئيه هناك
اتهام بالتفخيخ السد من قبل
الجانب الروسي وايضا يعني يتهموا الجانب
الاوكراني بذلك وجانب الروسي يتهم
الاوكرانيين بقصفه مدفعيا في عجاله ما
الذي ترشحه من خلال المعلومات وايضا ان
تضعه في سياق ما يجري من العمليه العسكريه
المضاده
يعني حتى اجيبك لابد ان اتطرق الى بعدين
من المستفيد ومن الذي يستطيع
في النقطه الاولى من المستفيد من وجهه نظر
عسكريه لانه هناك خسائر سيعاني منها
الجانبين لكن من منظور عسكري بحت وفي ظل
الحديث عن الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني كافه
التحليلات والقراءه المعمقه للخارقه
للخارطه والقدرات القتاليه للجانب
الاوكراني في ظل المعدات التي وصلت كانت
منطقه خرسون تمثل احد اتجاهات الهجوم
وبالتالي كانم المتوقع ان يكون الهجوم من
ثلاثه اتجاهات احدها ويمثل الجهد الثانوي
او المساند ياتي من خرسون باتجاه شبه
جزيره القرم في حال تفجير السد الان تم
انشاء مانع صناعي من خلال تغريق الارض
بعمق خمسه كيلو مترات واصبح يصعب جدا على
الجيش الاوكراني ان يقوم بتلك المناوره
السؤال الثاني من الذي يستطيع الان هذا
السد تحت السيطره الروسيه انا اتحدث في
بعد فني واقول هذا السد يحجز خلفه
بحيره 240 كيلو متر بعرض 23 كيلو متر بعمق
اكثر من 17 متر للمياه يحجز خلفه اكثر من
18 مليار متر مكعب وبالتالي هذا يجب ان
يكون مصمم بطريقه يتحمل كل هذه التحديات
الحديث الروسي عن تدمير من خلال
راجمات فيلكا وهي تحمل رؤوس متفجره بزنه
250 كيلو جرام
ولديها دقه على المسافات القريبه عشره متر
على المسافات البعيده 20 متر فنيا وبناء
على تصميم وانا بحكم خبرتي كظابط هندسه
اقول احتماليه التفجير بالصواريخ او
المدفعيه لا اقول معدومه ولكنها ضعيفه جدا
هذا السد حتى يفجر يجب ان يتم استخدام ما
يطلق عليه بالحشوات الغاطسه اللاصقه وتقاس
بالعطنان من المتفجرات العجينيه ار دي اكس
او ما يماثلها من المتفجرات الشرقيه يتوضا
بنظام هندسي محدد على ارتفاع معين من سطح
الارض وعلى عمق معين في المياه وتفجر في
لحظه واحده وعن بعد الان من الذي ايسر له
ان ينفذها الجانب الروسي هل يعني ذلك ان
الجانب الاوكراني لا يستطيع اقول يستطيع
من خلال الضفادع البشري المدربه ولكن
يفترض بان هذا الجسر محمي
ان جميع الهجمات العكسيه الاوكرانيه فشلت
حتى محاولتهم اجتياح الحدود الروسيه كما
تعلمين في بلجراد ان اوكرانيا لا تتحمل
مسؤوليتها وترمي العمليات على عاتق
المجموعات المسمى باحرار روسيا علما ان
المعدات المستخدمه في الهجمات غربيه ان
هناك حوالي خمس مئه جندي في نفدنس قتل
وعشرات المعدات وكان هناك معركه طالت لعشر
ساعات ولم تستطيع اوكرانيا ان تنجح باي
شيء اريد ان اقول لكم تعديل صغير لم تدمر
لم يدمر السد بل هناك فتحه تشكلت اريد ان
اقول ان الصواريخ التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا
تزن حوالي 250 كيلو متر لذلك
ضربه ضربه السد وتشكيل هذا الثقب شيء ممكن
في الواقع اما ما قاله السيد فايز هو شيء
قد لا اتفق معه
لان الجانب
الروسي هو من الجانب المتدني
حتى وان استطاع الجانب الروسي عفوا اذا
استطاع الجانب الاوكراني من التقدم كان
ليعلم في الطحل ولكن صيد ارطمانو يعني
سؤالي كان هو عن سياق عن سياق
الهجوم العكسي الهجوم المضاده الذي تتحدث
عنه جميع الاوساط بانه هو شيك او فعليا قد
بدا اريد تعليق في عجاله ما هي توقعاتك
بالنسبه للاماكن التي سيشملها في عجولك
انتقل الى ضيفه
قلت لك ان هذه الهجمات بدات وهم موجود
بدات في اوغلي دار وهناك خسرت القوات
الاوكرانيه حوالي 1500 جندي و30 دبابه
منها ثمانيه
ونحن نستخدم جميع القوات التي لدينا وكل
ما تقوم به اوكرانيا يفشل ليس لديهم ذخيره
وليس لديهم طائرات وليس لديهم دبابات
حقيقيه كما يتحدث عنه زيلينسكي او قضيه
جمع المعدات الغربيه هذا شيء مضحك
طيب نحن نتابع من جمله من العواجل التي
تظهر اذن معنا على الشاشه عن البيت الابيض
من المبكر ان نعرف التاثير الذي سيتركه
هجوم السد على ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا
نقلا عن البيت الابيض والضرر الذي سيحدثه
تفجير سادكو خوفك من المرجح ان يطال امن
الطاقه في اوكرانيا اذا ما وضعنا كل هذه
الصوره سيد الكسيف في كييف ضمن
عمليه التكتم والسريه التي تحيط بها
اوكرانيا
او تحاول ان تحيط بهذه العمليه المضاده
الهجوم العسكري المضاد ما نوع الترتيبات
التي ستكون بالنسبه
للمواجهه مع الجانب الروسي عند اي خطوط
اشتباك ستتركز من وجهه نظرك اذا ما وضعناه
ايضا في سياق حدث اليوم
ان اشاركك ببعض التقييمات لانه هناك اسباب
مفهومه ان عدد محدود جدا عدد محدود من
الاشخاص يحتوي على المعلومات الحقيقيه اما
عن ان اوكرانيا مستعده وتستعد بجديه طوال
الاشهر لهذه الهجمات وان عدد كبير من
المعدات الحديثه والجاده جدا فهذا
شيء حقيقي واوكرانيا لم تبدا الهجمات
العكسيه بعد ما يحصل هي عمليه تشكيليه
وهذا يعني ان اوكرانيا تحدد المناطق التي
سوف يكون فيها الضربات الاساسيه اما
بالنسبه
للقدرات الروسيه في الطائرات والمدفعيه
هذا كان شيء موجود لدى روسيا في العام
الماضي حيث استطاعت اوكرانيا بالتقدم في
خرسون وفي خارقه وبغض النظر عن القدرات
الروسيه
اوكرانيا ان تغرق
السفينه الحربيه ماسك
الروسيه لذلك اعتقد اننا سوف نحصل على
الردود المناسبه وعلى الاجوبه على اسئلتك
وسوف نشاهد قدرات اوكرانيا سيد فايزه
الدويري هل ما يحدث هو اذان بدخولنا مرحله
جديده
في هذا الصراع
ومنعطف الهجوم المضاد ام انه لا زالت هناك
مسافه تفصلنا فعليا عن بدئه
يعني الان
ازدادت الامور تعقيدا بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني لانه عليه ان يعيد تقييم الواقع
الجديد ومدى تاثيره على الخطه الهجوم التي
كانت يتم الاعداد لها منذ اشهر والان حدث
منعطف كبير جدا عليهم اعاده تقييم الوضع
على المستوى الاستراتيجي والعمليات
والتكتيكي ولا بد لهم ان يعدلوا الاطر
العامه للخطه لانه الان كقراءه سريعه على
مسافه
240 كم الى الشمال الشرقي من السد هذه
المنطقه لا يمكن ان يكون لديهم القدره على
استخدامها منطقه خرسون اصبح امامهم حاجز
طبيعي منطقه تم اغراقها بعمق خمسه كيلو
متر ما هي البدائل الموجوده عليهم ان
يبحثوا في منطقه شمال جابولوجيا وربما
وبالتالي اتجاه العمليات سيتم تغييره وهذا
يحتاج
الارض نعم خلط الاوراق العسكري على الارض
الاخير هل خرط ايضا سيد ارطمانو في موسكو
الاوراق
السياسيا خاصه مع محاولات خفض التصعيد
واحاديث عن ربما محاولات لعقد قمه للسلام
واحتماليه ايضا الدعوه لانعقاد مجلس الامن
لمناقشه التطورات في الحرب
ان كل الاوراق خلطت عند العسكريين
الاوكرانيين وهم ينتظروا الاوامر من قبل
السيد
الزاوجسكي الذي يختبئ لذلك من الواضح ان
الحديث الان ليس عن السلام خاصه من الطرف
الاوكراني وليس من الواضح من اين سيبدا
الاوكرانيين هجماتهم لانهم لا يملكون اي
قدرات لذلك من وجهه نظري اما بالنسبه
لاحتياطاتهم فهي قليله
سيد افهم منك ايضا رايك بهذا السياق الى
اي درجه
كيف هي معنيه باصوات البنادق الان اكثر
منها باصوات السلام والحوار
ليس لدى اوكرانيا اي مخرج اخر الا
الاستمار في المعارك لانها اذا وضعت
سلاحها فهذا سيعني تجميد للمعارك وحسب
وهذا سيشكل امكانيه لروسيا حتى يتحضروا
لمرحله جديده من العدوان لذلك اوكرانيا
مصره على ان تقوم بهزيمه روسيا هجيم هزيمه
نهائيه على ارض المعركه
وروسيا يجب ان تفشل وتهزم في اغلب جبهات
المعركه واوكرانيا يجب ان تصل الى
ضفاف بحر الازوف ثم تحرير القرم وهذا يجب
ان يشكل هزيمه حقيقيه للروس وللعالم كله
شكرا لك من
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق
واشكر ضيف ايضا من موسكو الكسندر ارتمان
نوف الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه والدوليه
وايضا من عمان اللواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا لكم جميعا
هناك تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]